-We have a big show tonight,
everybody.
Hillary Rodham Clinton
is my guest tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And compared to the Democrat
you saw last night,
she looks like a tween.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
last night was Super Tuesday
and today for Mike Bloomberg
it was, "Oh, my God. I waste
a billion dollars" Wednesday
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
last night was Super Tuesday
and the big winner
was Joe Biden.
After finishing --
[ Applause ]
Yeah, after finishing fourth i
Iowa and fifth in New Hampshire,
Biden won 10 states.
It's like going from the middl
seat on Spirit Airlines
to Beyoncé's private jet.
[ Stammers ]
Seriously, no one saw Bide
becoming the front-runner again.
Right now,
even Jesus is thinking,
"Wow, this is a crazy comeback."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Biden had a great night.
And you could tell
things were going well for him
Just look at the photos
the TV networks showed
every time he won another state.
First, when he won Alabama
they showed this.
Then when he won
Virginia, they showed this
[ Laughter ]
Then when he won North Carolina,
they showed this.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, when he won Texas
they showed this.
[ Stammers ] That's fantastic.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Actually, there was a --
There was a scary moment
last night
during Biden's victory speec
when a woman stormed the stage
Thankfully,
no charges were pressed,
and she was able to be
our lead guest tonight.
Hillary Clinton is here,
ladies and gentlemen!
No, no, I'm joking.
♪♪♪♪
That's right, though.
Protesters rushed the stage,
and Biden's wife, Dr. Jill
Biden, stepped in to stop them
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
Forget First Lady. She should be
Secretary of Defense.
[ Laughter ]
The bad news is, this morning,
Jill got drafted
by the Cincinnati Bengals.
[ Audience groans ]
That's not the only moment
during Biden's speech
that people are talking about.
Things started out
with a pretty bad mix-up.
Take a look.
-By the way, this is
my little sister, Valerie,
and I'm Jill's husband.
Oh, no, this is --
Oh, you switched on me.
This is my wife.
This is my sister.
[ Laughter ]
-After saying that,
Biden automatically won
the state of West Virginia
so congrats. Good for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey-oh! Oh! Hey!
Hey, forget about it!
[ Laughter ]
-Trump saw that and was like
"Dear God. He's unstoppable.
He's --"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Bernie Sanders also
had a decent night.
Unfortunately,
when he thanked his supporters
he got a little too big
with his gestures.
Look what happened.
-But for the years and years
of love and support
you have given me and my family.
[ Cheers ]
[ Laughter ]
-Poor Bernie. That was
a week's worth of Metamucil.
You understand?
I mean, that's --
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-But it wasn't a great night
for Mike Bloomberg.
He spent his Super Tuesday
in Florida,
and after the disappointin
results came in,
he tried cheering himself up
by buying a theme park.
That's right, Super Tuesda
went so poorly for Bloomberg
that this morning,
he dropped out of the race
But good news, Mike -- Compare
to de Blasio and Giuliani,
you're still every New Yorker'
favorite mayor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course, Super Tuesday was
a big night for the news media
and they really went all-out
to cover the Democrats,
bringing on as many anchor
and analysts as they could
I'll show you what I mean.
This was CBS.
Yeah. That's one desk
with five people.
That's pretty standard
right there.
And here's ABC.
-And Michael Bloomberg.
-They did three desks
with 13 people.
I mean, that's kind of a lot
right there.
Yeah. Now, here's MSNBC.
They used the set
for "Hollywood Squares."
Not sure that's a great idea
[ Laughter ]
Now here's CNN.
They had a Ferris wheel
rotating 40 anchors
in and out of frame.
Now, that's a good idea.
And finally, here's Fox News
It was just an empty chair and a
sign that says, "No news today."
[ Applause ]
Well, guys, the coronaviru
is still going around.
and to help stop it
from spreading,
experts are telling people t
avoid any kinds of handshakes.
Health officials are
actually recommending
doing something
called footshakes.
Have you seen this?
Take a look at this.
This is real.
[ People speaking indistinctly ]
It's a footshake, yeah.
I think it's --
I think it's great.
Tariq, you want to try it out?
-Sure.
-Let's do it. Come on, man
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think we stand --
I think we just stand here
and then we just start.
Ready? Nice to see ya.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Like that? Yeah.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That wasn't too hard.
Tariq Trotter, everybody!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckling ] Gosh.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Some local news.
By the end of the month,
New York City will remove
some of its last remaining
street pay phones.
Yeah, officials said, "Sorry
but you're going to have to find
somewhere else to urinate.
[ Laughter ]
And this is crazy. I read abou
two women in Pennsylvania
who have been best friends
for 17 years
and just found out
that they're actually sisters.
Yeah. And ever since that,
they haven't stopped fighting.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
an American Airlines fligh
was diverted
to a different airport
after a passenger tried
to open a door mid-flight.
In the passenger's defense
the in-flight movie was "Cats.
We have a great show!